we ain't get no younger as well do this
girl you oh no you're not girl boy ya
[ __ ] boy
let's get married just go up or now oh
god he's not he's not he's not picking
up what I'm laying down I love it giving
you a hand
what's going on dad we'll do that that's
that's good that's good all right good
thank you
jagged edge babe I love jagged edges get
married
Highschool jagged edges today yes we all
right don't get all sensitive talking
judges Jack and juice Jack and Jews
second Jesus dude I try to pool earlier
just now really know anything cuz
nothing came out
oh you were just nervous I want to know
what you out this is what my question
with you like for me when I have to poo
by the time my ass cheeks hit the seat
yeah there's no question stuff's gonna
come out my butt it's never a will it or
will it not because your [ __ ] isn't
shadow games I play shadow games with me
so you get the sensation and sometimes
nothing comes out
same here just now I'll go oh my god I
got to take a big dump Don he runs to
the bat I walk in there and I squeeze
and I think I just unloaded a bunch in
there and look down it's gone that's
called having an obstruction what is
obstructing is that's why you have a toy
car in there
why because track I've always wanted
agree okay let's start like a retired
racing greyhound we can't use any of
these all of it five four three two I'm
really getting into bossanova
Stan Gates and Rudra Bank and Gregor
under a car loan rather whatever strewed
right those two are great welcome to
another episode of tiger belly it's a
new me Theo Wong I'm Theo Wong now you
know how many [ __ ] [ __ ]
comedians at the Comedy Store
it's
like did you get that because a Theo mmm
it's like no [ __ ] does he own it first
of all when an Asian gets a mullet it's
a completely different thing all the
[ __ ] health crises no no but you know
it's like 1970s I have a machete I'm in
Saigon and I'm ready to chops things up
look you know I mean when a white dude
gets a mullet it's southern it's you
know me in America it's America USA USA
it's two different things
and and it's also what there's ten
haircuts I can't have one because [ __ ]
it I'm gonna do a Hitler mustache - yeah
I mean I can do what I want with my face
and my hair because it's America it's an
open country right look at yours you
have that Timothy McVeigh vibe always
that's your choice right just don't blow
anything up you have a 1950s Elvis II he
you know flat face thing yum-yum you
babe oh please don't get started
anything I'm having insecurities island
creatures haven't stopped eating for
three weeks guys and no I'm not pregnant
Jesus that's what they you know what
he's calling me lately wait why did you
just throw that out there because she
wants me to call her beefy because he is
people will assume oh you're easy maybe
you have a [ __ ] bun in the oven but
you know what every night he's not
helping my um my self-esteem every every
time he passes by me he calls me he
calls me the beef Bryn says yeah is this
a high school locker he says he's like
well babe looking really beefy let me
ask you something okay and of complim
when you don't have prime rib in the
house if you've never cooked a prime rib
in the house and you smell it in your
bed it's beef time you've made that
worse dude hold on do I smell like beet
or not or a live cow you seem it's like
medium rare well that's pretty tasty
that's pretty Tex high quality yeah no
I'm kidding baby it's a comedy podcast
and we just throw things out there you
go you brought it up right you're
calling me you've heard the hallways
what the guy's cool boy come back from
yoga he's like nope not less beef
and after we had her bullet I'm not
pulling her we had her New Year's kiss
he goes do you know what I want because
do you know what I want this year
he's like less beef more you Jesus yeah
let's beef Morgan it is that so wrong to
ask for good slow I'm going to a
meetings I'm sober 40 days all he's
asking is less I mean I just want less
beef my friend and then this she's super
sick and yesterday Oh God